une voix la sensibilisation on a enfin
une espèce d'oiseau qui vit près des
gens comme un dieu parce que chez les
gens parce qu'elle est dans leur
cheminée et puis même si on veut sauver
le marché mais les aider mais les
propriétaires de maison d'église de
producteurs d'école d'inscrits commerce
dans lequel il est sublime édité par de
martinez mais chacun fait des efforts de
médiation mis en place de ce problème
pour le martinet et mais avec une
contribution je pense important à la
sauvegarde dans la mesure où la cheminée
damas et pas dangereuse tout ce qui est
six fois que l'on a vu certains cas où
les cheminées de très vieilles et on le
mort qui était faisant sûr que les
libristes est tombé c'est sûr comme manu
une question sécurité publique ou
peut-être pensé en avant de remercier et
on prenait des personnes je pense
notamment à quelqu'un a grimpé la
mauricie quand même fait rénover sa
cheminée pour la garde est disponible
pour les matinées la façon de sécuriser
et puis en remplacement pour ses propres
besoins de chauffage s'est construit son
propre cheminement maintenant qui est un
métal mais la cheminée utilisé pour le
match ne demeurent disponibles pour pour
le marché donc c'est un bel exemple des
formes que les citoyens peuvent à peu
près ça reprend sans doute que certains
coûts parce que je suis de la maçonnerie
mais bon certains comme un ex aequo
notamment des coûts très élevés
la coop en prévenant financière qui
conservent leurs semis mais c'est sûr
que ce serait intéressant pour l'instant
c'est juste au québec on connaître ses
seins cheminée qui ont
été utilisé par le martinet donc on peut
ici sans propriétaire de mon soleil ne
serait ce qu un petit montant s'ajoute
aux antilles des courts essais sustenter
à comps propriétaire l'homme les avait
vus sensibiliser de sa possible non plus
propriétaire n'ont pas nécessairement
été sensibilisés approcher un parent ça
c'est pour moi quelque chose qui va
venir dans dans le futur mais pour
l'instant il plusieurs propriétaires qui
ont des moeurs feu dans la cheminée qui
ne savent même pas parce que c'est pas
un oiseau très beau très beau rien donc
ça donne aussi une idée que c'est pas
très dérangeant pour les gens de garder
dans leur chute
fulham a reculé parce qu'il ya des gens
qui en ont besoin